well the gun that's just like the the
the Foley guys races right right
[Laughter]
[Music]
all right since all of us in here are
the experts at judging racism yes we're
gonna watch some classic racist Asian
moments in cinema
kind of random
random that's the worst so this one is
from A Christmas Story I don't know if
you've ever seen that class oh I love
Christmas Story there's a little scene
where there's these guys at a Chinese
restaurant called The Chop Suey Palace
is that at the end oh hell yeah I don't
know if it's at the end I've never
actually seen the movie oh you have it
but there's a part where these three
dudes are like waiters are singing and
they make them sing like stereotypical
Chinese oh I remember this one like I am
siamese if you please yeah no not as bad
as that
Deck the Halls
[Music]
[Laughter]
jari
able
is that not that bad I have an old Asian
man correcting the other yeah he's like
the head Mater dude whatever that's
that's not racist right he's just trying
to help them with their English
well what it says is that like it
perpetuates the idea that like oh
anytime you hear of an Asian person with
an accent it's supposed to be funny can
it is funny
[Laughter]
all accents are funny though
funny though French accents are
hilarious
it's like Colleen how do you feel about
that I feel like it's funny I mean
they're all funny British accents funny
yeah when you do Australians funny New
Zealand no I take the hit from it's
funny yeah it's all funny dude I think
it's all funny but one out of ten racism
that's like a one dude yeah bro yeah
yeah like when when David does an
African accent hilarious by the way yeah
it should be said there was massive
reparations for that scene when they
remade Christmas Story and it's a pretty
funny bit really really so it's Ken Jong
in the same exact scene they remade it
yeah they remade it yeah and look at
this
story live
expecting that
what were you expecting because they
think they sing it totally normal
yeah yeah yeah it's like what do you
mean you people it's like that right
right so that's a really really good
that's 10 out of 10 racism yeah that was
too racist yeah oh the remix races can
John's racist a James Bond movie called
You Only Live Twice It's an odd job wow
uh there's a scene where they make him
like uh look Japanese
they look Japanese wait but he's a spy
though
he has one on the cover yeah what if
he's like super stereo it's a
life-sensitive situation part of the
plot though I don't know about that all
there bond is given a makeover to look
Japanese
so Vietnamese girl makes him look
they're mad because all they did was
give him bushes
what do you think expert Japanese guy
and they should what they should have
done I think that's [__] hilarious
but we're also looking at it from
today's lens oh yeah she was like true
movie Magic back then and also
people's like um what do you call it
there was much more Dumber so like it
was easy to wow them like you know to me
that is like going into a disguise shop
and buying the nose and glass attachment
thing oh yeah you know and then like in
a cartoon when you wear that everyone's
like oh that's not Joe you know what I
mean but then you take it off and
they're like oh my God that's true right
and then to me like that's that's
probably like during that era they would
go oh my God he looks so Japanese
because they're stupid yeah like like
they would have uh what's his name like
like [__] David Carradine's Chinese
yeah yeah right isn't he half asian
though he's not huh I don't think he is
I don't know yeah but that is like
watching RoboCop back then and it was
like mind-blowing right and then now you
watch and you're like that CG is
horrible it doesn't hold up looks like
it's stop motion picture so Heron makeup
Department team didn't have the right
tools no yeah and and I would say and I
would have tape to pull his eyes back
yeah they needed Scotch tape back then
they only had duct tape Scotch tape
exactly but uh obviously this is not a
this is not a justification and not to
make things all serious and [__] but
like
I'm also so I'm also accepting of the
fact that like during that time right if
they all
film Evolution right it came from
theater right and from theater you just
played characters you wore costumes and
did that stuff but also races were
costumes if we look back now and go like
oh yeah Minstrel stuff is bad all this
stuff is bad right but during that time
like it was a uh actor played a role and
then you became the thing well like
whether you were white or whatever like
men were playing women most of the time
exactly and then that's and they were
good at it better better than any woman
and they nailed it
so I don't know like they would get too
emotional
I mean yeah I mean like so so the the so
the on the flip side right it's like
saying it's like saying um well you
should have find an Asian bond to play
an Asian but I'm like we're talking
about 19 freaking 60. we only had like
what maybe Bruce Lee I don't even know
anything you know this is where you're
wrong though dude because remember in
the movie Mission Impossible three Ghost
Protocol
Tom Cruise yeah does that right yeah he
had to be a little a little bit later
but it's still spy so it's the same Bart
okay okay please please don't interrupt
me
he plays Philip Seymour Hoffman remember
he has the mass yep they did the whole
thing and he put it on he looked like
Philip Seymour Hoffman why couldn't they
do that for this movie
again they didn't have the proper
personalities
their makeup department but they're all
spies right so stop making excuses you
know what I don't like about
um judging the past with the current
lens they don't give homage to the uh
the steps that it took to get here oh so
like for me what I see is post World War
II Japan and America relationships right
it's like 1960 or whatever when this
came out yeah
ten years ago from that it was Japanese
internment cats [__] Japanese kill them
on the streets right and then this I see
it as a film of hey we're working
together now with the Japanese okay when
you put it that way that's very but
that's all part of the the context of
social fabric of everything so it's like
it's like healing the relationship
through Cinema of like here's Bond
working in Japan with allies that are
Japanese where the Bond movies back then
British Productions technically still
yeah but but Japanese was an Axis power
so they would have looked at them as
like the foreign threat right got it
yeah yeah so it's like the Western world
it's like inviting like a former enemy
into the reparations kind of like James
Bond the guy so before we can even get
to the whole like Asian American thing
like that creature today you have to
first get to the healing the two Nations
thing it's like footsteps it's like baby
steps yes yeah you know what I never
thought of that that's a really cool
opinion Joe Knows history so racism zero
out of ten okay zero out of two what do
we think about this guy right here
oh yeah oh my favorite dong
they got a Gong yeah every time
the unwarranted gong sound that follows
gone
it's so loud
that's good number five no you don't
like them well they're gone that's just
like the the the Foley guys races right
right
holy [__]
[Laughter]
just go crazy let's go crazy yeah what
if that was Nick's dad yeah
he's looking at the horse with the
footsteps oh [__]
God damn it we missed the Cube It's the
Foley guy that's racist yeah dude that
guy's racist dude
well we figured that out zero out of ten
what would the sound be for other
ethnicities if the Asian guy gets the
gong well I don't think there's one
that's synonymous what would it be a
sound for white people right well we
have no culture uh yeah I guess it's
like it's easier when it's European
right because if it's a German guy then
it's like polka if it's a Scottish guy's
bagpipes or something yeah yeah
they do that but it's hard like I mean
country music but if like what if you're
like from New York it's not country yes
yeah that's that's why it's hard yeah
that is true all right we're gonna look
at the most classic of all
is that Mickey Rooney oh you bet it is
this was racism
pretty hardcore
this one's gonna score decently High one
they say breath less
they made that food extra
ugly see I think James Bond needed his
outfit look at this food darling I am
sorry but I lost my keys
it was it was wrong then see accent not
very good not very good at uh so so do
you think if he executed it better it
wouldn't be as racist I would like less
folds of the forehead why did they give
them those circle glasses I feel like I
met someone like that in a Little Tokyo
before that
it's my stupid Judo teacher
yeah
with defensive Asian accent and wearing
a mouthpiece yeah he's just always like
blinking all the time
he literally picked one of the worst I
know that guy exists all right I'm not
saying this but like you picked that
thing to like funny you know was that
this what year was that 1960 something
yes please
yeah yeah yeah yeah you're 1960s that
says you know
it's pretty racist it's that one's that
one's pretty bad that's rough out of all
of them that's the worst one yeah I
think like for me I have a lot of
leniency towards racism because uh I it
depends on their intention so with James
Bond he's going undercover it's driven
by the plot okay and it's a horrible job
but he went undercover but if you just
need a Japanese neighbor you can cast a
Japanese name yeah yeah you know I mean
you don't have to like oh [__] we need a
German Shepherd can jump in a fursuit
yeah yeah yeah get a German Shepherd to
be in the movie but also too based on
the character he's supposed to be like
not very likable right so they play it
up even more they get Mickey Rooney or
whatever the [__] guy to play him and be
completely over the top and obnoxious so
that's where it's like all right dude
what are we doing yeah that's where it
came that's true because then you're
taking all the undesirable traits of a
stereotype right so it's like it's
almost like if you had like a like a
cheap Chinese landlord that was always
like trying to raise the rent on you and
you're just like oh you [__]
[__] unless they are striking according
people were like showing them something
like this is gonna make people go they
are like that yeah yeah yeah yeah you
know what I mean like that's not fair
but also if they were gonna be more
accurate I think it was a Japanese
person I think they'd be way more polite
oh you know what I'm saying it was a
Japanese yeah bro Japanese landlord they
would knock on the door and be like
excuse me I'm sorry like I think they'd
be more like that but if he was
Taiwanese see that's that's more
accurate Cantonese though yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah they just mixed up the races
yeah they always do that even with long
duck dog in the game of freaking Vietnam
and he's supposed to be Japanese isn't
he I I don't even think that's a
Vietnamese name oh the actor is Japanese
playing a Chinese guy with a Viet name I
think is the is the meme that's not even
a Vietnam
um
there's one there's one of them there's
a long I don't think there's a dog
there's no duck wait there's no dong
what if it was just made up because they
think it was a funny name oh yeah
there's got to be like duct tape
yeah
there's duck somewhere I mean that's
definitely the the main gripe is that at
least back then in terms when people are
making Cinema and representing Asians
bad leads that they're giving them the
character nobody likes like oh you're
the ugly guy you're the guy that won't
date anybody or the nerd you're the
sleazeball you're annoying you're loud
you suck in the Bruce Lee movie
um the biopic Dragon he walks out of the
movie when he saw that so Bruce Lee he
sees that scene he walks out the movie
he watches breakfast activities in in
the movies they portray that and he goes
and he gets up and he leaves I mean he
did wonders against this 100 he changed
the game yeah without Bruce we'd be in
trouble yeah we've been trouble what
about Donnie Yen now Tony Ann's like a
modern day Bruce he's a man yeah he's a
man he's pretty sick yeah he's always
blind though hey dude stop being blind
and moving [__] eyes at work come on
bro two movies in a row he's blind wait
what was the other one that he was born
he was blind in Rogue one would you feel
bad if it turned out he was really blind
like it is old age yeah
[Music]
yeah I feel bad I feel bad I feel bad
but it's like what a coincidence dude
he's like like so okay we're talking
about jungle just real quick I didn't
watch it again I know but all you need
to know is that Donnie Yen's in it he's
great but he's blind and he does cool
[__] based off him being blind which is
tight and it's fun but it's also like
did he need to be blind here's the thing
I like the beginning how they added
certain things I'm not going to give it
away for people who haven't seen it yeah
there are certain techniques that he
does in the beginning and I'm like okay
cool that adds to his character for
being blind but then throughout the
movie it's just completely forgotten now
he's just a God now he's just can
basically see he's also like like John
are you there and then also like
grabbing like yeah he's doing this and
then and then someone shoots a sniper
shoots him and he goes yeah
which what is it dude is he blood or
does he have the force
[Laughter]
or assisted him with that but then as
soon as it got towards the middle and
I'm like all right well this guy's just
God yeah Donna Reeves is Asian too right
yeah he's something see the Asian or
Jason he's half right C there it is
let's see I never noticed that that is
pretty funny about uh it was funny like
being deaf and then going did you guys
[__] hear that
all right
[Music]